i think blake and i were very fortunate
enough to recognize
things early
and
i don't know made the best decision for
us i don't know it's a lot
i didn't expect to like
do this but um katie thurston is getting
emotional following her split from
fiance blake moines
sorry
oh
i just want to say thank you that's it
like really that's all it comes down to
um
yeah obviously it's a lot the former
bachelorette took to instagram over the
weekend to talk about her breakup for
the first time captioning the clip quote
just venting and while discussing life
post engagement she begins to cry i
think blake and i were very fortunate
enough to recognize
things early
and
i don't know made the best decision for
us
that doesn't come with its own
challenges like we
are still processing a lot of like
waves of emotion like
i don't know it's a lot
i didn't expect to like
do this but um
yeah i don't know i just wanted to hop
on and just say thank you
katie also revealed why they decided to
end their relationship a lot of people
are like well what really happened
what's the big thing that happened with
with katie and blake and it's like
we were together for six months
blake and i are very
level-headed and mature and we
communicate very well on our thoughts
and
we just both knew like if this is how
our first six months
was as a couple
going forward it was going to
not be in our best interest for our
happiness
to stay together
and so we you know as mentioned mutually
decided to part our ways katie's video
comes just days after she and blake
announced their split in a joint
statement fans speculated that they had
called it quits after noticing the
couple wasn't liking each other's recent
social media posts and when e.t spoke
with the two back in august after blake
had popped the question katie lane first
will you marry me
they both had said they were in it for
the long haul these past couple months
have been amazing we've grown so much
since that proposal that you guys have
seen and i think it just shows like how
far we are gonna go together like this
really isn't just a temporary
relationship i do feel very confident we
are going to be together forever yeah
100
i mean i came on here guns of blazing
knowing that she was going to be the one
and uh it turned out that way and
honestly it's just been
it's just been everything i thought it
was going to be and more and while
things may not have worked out for katie
current bachelorette michelle young is
now on her journey to find love
he's got brains he's got beauty he's got
swag what more could a girl ask for
back in july katie revealed to et the
advice she shared with michelle ahead of
her experience the biggest advice i've
given her is to just be open you know
don't close yourself off too early i
think guys can surprise you
you know weeks later when you don't
expect it